Mes frères, voici comment je m'adresse à vous ce matin.
Voici comment Jacques, le frère de Jésus-Christ, le pasteur de l'église de Jérusalem,
la colonne de l'église selon l'apôtre Paul lui-même, s'adressa aussi aux membres de ces églises auxquelles il envoya sa lettre.
Par trois fois, il s'adresse à eux de cette manière au chapitre 1 et par trois fois encore au chapitre 2.
Et cela nous donne déjà deux informations contextuelles précieuses pour cette prédication et pour l'ensemble de cette lettre.
Premièrement, cette lettre est adressée à des chrétiens.
Donc toutes les exhortations que nous y lisons nous concernent, nous, chrétiens.
Deuxièmement, Jacques connaissait très probablement plusieurs des membres de ces églises,
car ces églises se sont formées après que de nombreux chrétiens, majoritairement d'origine juive,
ont dû fuir Jérusalem à cause de la persécution.
Jacques était un des anciens de l'église de Jérusalem, comme je viens de le dire,
et il devait donc connaître personnellement plusieurs de ces personnes.
Et il était en tout cas très au courant des raisons de leur départ ainsi que de leur situation de vie actuelle.
Et nous pourrions croire que ce deuxième point n'est qu'une information de contexte,
mais ce serait une erreur.
D'ailleurs, c'est toujours une erreur de croire que nous pouvons bien interpréter un texte biblique en dehors de son contexte historique,
contexte qui cadre et oriente notre compréhension tant de la forme que du fond du texte,
que des intentions de son auteur.
Voici quelques exemples d'exhortations de Jacques que nous lisons dès les premières lignes de sa lettre,
qu'il adresse à des frères et sœurs en Christ persécutés,
qu'il connaît, en tout cas pour certains, et qu'il affectionne.
Dès le deuxième verset du chapitre 1,
« Regardez comme un sujet de joie complète les diverses épreuves auxquelles vous pouvez être exposés. »
Treizième verset du chapitre 1,
« Que personne, lorsqu'il est tenté, ne dise « C'est Dieu qui me tente. » »
Verset 26,
« Si quelqu'un croit être religieux sans tenir sa langue en bride, mais en trompant son cœur,
la religion de cet homme est vaine. »
Ne vous semble-t-il pas dur de la part de Jacques d'adresser ces mots à des frères en Christ
dont ils connaissent les souffrances physiques ?
Ils ont subi la persécution.
Les souffrances matérielles, ils ont laissé tout leur bien derrière eux,
en tout cas une grande partie, en fuyant cette ville.
Les souffrances relationnelles, ils ont dû abandonner aussi de la famille, des amis,
peut-être même en ont-ils perdu certains.
Et les souffrances humaines,
ils subissent un changement de vie drastique et brutal,
qu'ils n'ont pas choisi.
Ne s'attendrait-on pas à trouver, au moins,
une introduction un peu plus longue,
avec des mots un peu plus chaleureux,
réconfortants, encourageants,
pour ces frères qui souffrent tant ?
Pourquoi Jacques commence-t-il sa lettre
en exhortant ces chrétiens persécutés à progresser dans leur foi,
en les reprenant sur leur mauvaise manière d'aborder leur souffrance,
leur mauvaise manière de prier,
de penser, de réfléchir,
ou encore d'écouter la parole de Dieu ?
Je pense que nous pouvons identifier trois raisons que vous devez garder à l'esprit
afin de comprendre l'ensemble des exhortations de Jacques dans sa lettre
et comment les mettre aussi en pratique dans votre vie.
Tout d'abord, le fait que Jacques corrige et reprenne des chrétiens
qu'il connaît, qu'il aime et qui subissent la persécution
nous montre qu'aucune circonstance de notre vie,
même les plus dures,
ne nous dispense d'obéir à Dieu,
de progresser en sainteté
et d'être repris au sujet de notre péché.
Et à quel point ce rappel est pertinent aujourd'hui,
surtout pour les plus jeunes générations peut-être,
dans lesquelles je m'inclus encore,
et qui ont cette tendance,
il faut le reconnaître,
à se plaindre plus facilement des difficultés de la vie
et surtout à justifier leur péché
ou leur manque de progrès spirituel par ces difficultés.
Car voici ce que Jacques n'hésite pas à dire
à des chrétiens qui sont tentés de justifier leur péché
par la trop grande dureté des épreuves
par lesquelles Dieu les fait passer à ce moment de leur vie.
Voici ce qu'il leur dit.
Que personne, lorsqu'il est tenté,
ne dit « c'est Dieu qui me tente ».
Car Dieu ne peut être tenté par le mal
et il ne tente lui-même personne.
Mais chacun est tenté
quand il est attiré et amorcé
par sa propre convoitise.
Puis la convoitise,
lorsqu'elle a conçu en fente le péché
et le péché étant consommé,
produit la mort.
Pour paraphraser Jacques,
c'est comme s'il nous disait
« peu importe vos circonstances de vie,
si vous péchez,
c'est que vous êtes tenté par votre propre convoitise.
Et si vous accusez la souveraineté de Dieu
pour justifier votre péché,
alors vous mourrez dans votre péché. »
Cela est vrai si nous devons être confrontés
ou si nous devons confronter.
Car on peut aussi,
comme nous le voyons en ce moment
dans notre série sur la crainte de l'homme
le vendredi soir,
craindre l'homme plus que Dieu,
ne pas vouloir être vu comme une personne dure,
insensible,
et ne pas confronter le péché,
les mauvaises pensées,
les mauvaises paroles,
les mauvaises décisions
d'un frère ou d'une sœur
sous prétexte
qu'il ou elle souffre dans sa vie.
Bien entendu,
nous devons toujours être sensibles
à la souffrance réelle
de notre prochain,
adapter notre manière
d'aborder le sujet
en fonction de la situation de chacun.
Mais personne ne peut se prévaloir
des circonstances de sa vie
pour ne pas confronter le péché de son frère
ou ne pas recevoir
la juste confrontation de son frère.
Ces avertissements sont sévères,
mais ils sont tout à fait nécessaires.
Pourquoi sont-ils nécessaires ?
Cela nous amène à la deuxième raison
pour laquelle Jacques exhorte vivement
ses chrétiens à l'obéissance
et à la persévérance,
malgré les persécutions
et ses conséquences humaines terribles.
Il ne veut surtout pas
que ses frères et sœurs
endurent tout cela en vain.
Heureux l'homme qui supporte
patiemment la tentation,
car après avoir été éprouvé,
il recevra la couronne de vie
que le Seigneur a promise
à ceux qui l'aiment.
Verset 12 du chapitre 1.
Et ce verset résume parfaitement
le désir profond du cœur pastoral de Jacques,
qui l'a poussé à rédiger cette lettre.
Quoi de pire, en effet,
que de subir l'épreuve
pour échouer au milieu
ou juste à la fin ?
Jacques veut encourager ses frères et sœurs.
Leurs souffrances ont un sens.
Elles en valent la peine,
car au terme de ses afflictions terrestres,
c'est la couronne de vie,
la gloire éternelle,
la consolation parfaite,
le bonheur infini
qui attend ceux
qui persévéreront jusqu'au bout.
Ce désir qui l'anime
lui vient du Saint-Esprit,
évidemment,
qui a inspiré des mots similaires
à Pierre dans sa première lettre
qui sont d'un grand réconfort
lorsque la vie nous semble longue
et difficile.
Et je voudrais vous lire ces versets.
1 Pierre 1, verset 6 à 7.
qui ont aujourd'hui à trouver
leur assurance
et leur joie
tout au long de leur pèlerinage terrestre,
précisément dans leur persévérance
face aux épreuves de leur vie.
Car en effet,
la route peut sembler longue,
trop longue,
jusqu'à la gloire.
Pourquoi,
durant ce cheminement éprouvant,
devons-nous regarder
comme un sujet de joie complète
les diverses épreuves
auxquelles nous pouvons être exposés ?
Eh bien,
parce que ces épreuves,
frères et sœurs,
sont autant de preuves
que nous sommes
les enfants de Dieu.
Dieu,
notre bon Père,
utilise ces épreuves
pour nous sanctifier,
pour nous préparer
à la vie éternelle.
Et chaque pas de fidélité
que nous faisons
dans l'épreuve,
dont certaines sont
à peine surmontables
humainement parlant,
est une preuve
que le Saint-Esprit
nous soutient,
au cœur du creuset
par lequel le Père
nous fait passer,
pour nous purifier
à l'image de son Fils.
Voici comment l'auteur
aux Hébreux
décrit ces épreuves
dans la vie du chrétien.
Mon fils,
ne méprise pas
le châtiment du Seigneur
et ne perd pas courage
lorsqu'il te reprend,
car le Seigneur
châtie celui qu'il aime
et il frappe de la verge
tous ceux qu'il reconnaît
pour ses fils.
Il est vrai
que tous châtiments
sont d'abord
un sujet de tristesse
et non de joie,
mais il produit plus tard
pour ceux qui ont été
ainsi exercés
un fruit paisible
de justice.
Voici donc
comment Jacques vise
à encourager
les frères de ces églises
et nous ce matin
dans les épreuves
qu'ils traversent,
que vous traversez peut-être.
Ne justifions pas
notre péché
par la dureté
de ces épreuves,
mais considérons
les mêmes avec joie,
parce qu'elles sont
le signe
de la discipline paternelle
de notre Dieu
qui nous prépare
pour la gloire à venir.
Priez avec foi
que le pauvre
se glorifie
et le riche
s'humilie en Christ,
résister à la tentation,
écouter avec douceur
la parole de Dieu
et mettre en pratique
cette parole
par de bonnes œuvres
dans lesquelles
nous trouvons
notre joie.
Toutes ces exhortations
du chapitre 1
adressées par Jacques
le sont dans ce but
que nous continuions
de marcher
avec joie et assurance
vers la gloire éternelle
qui nous est assurée
et réservée
en Jésus-Christ.
Comme vous avez pu
le remarquer
en lisant cette lettre
ou le comprendre
à travers ce résumé
des intentions de Jacques,
son emphase
est très largement pratique.
Vous n'y trouverez pas
comme dans l'épître de Paul
aux Romains
ou aux Galates
par exemple
de grandes démonstrations
théologiques
sur la régénération
ou la distinction
entre loi et foi.
Pourtant,
il me semble important
de rappeler
que cette emphase
sur la vie pratique,
sur l'importance
des bonnes œuvres
ne doit pas nous faire croire
que Jacques enseigne
autre chose
que Paul.
Cette adresse,
mes frères,
montre clairement
qu'il est acquis
pour lui
qu'il s'adresse
à des chrétiens
et Jacques est très
au courant
de la doctrine
de la régénération
qui précède
nos bonnes œuvres
que le chrétien
peut accomplir
en Christ.
Lisons Jacques 1,
versets 18 à 19
pour nous assurer
de cela.
« Dieu nous a engendrés
selon sa volonté
par la parole de vérité
afin que nous soyons
en quelque sorte
les prémices
de ces créatures.
Sachez-le,
mes frères bien-aimés,
ainsi que tout homme
soit prompt
à écouter. »
Etc.
La structure
de ces versets,
notamment l'emplacement
du mot « ainsi »
montre clairement
que pour Jacques,
notre régénération,
notre nouvelle naissance
est faite
selon la volonté
de Dieu,
par sa parole,
et précède
et justifie
nos bonnes œuvres.
Nos bonnes œuvres
sont la conséquence
de notre régénération
et non l'inverse.
De plus,
n'oublions pas
un détail
qui a son importance,
que cette lettre
de Jacques
est très probablement
le texte le plus ancien
du Nouveau Testament
et que Paul aurait
largement eu l'occasion
de réfuter Jacques
si ce dernier
enseignait autre chose
que lui
à ce sujet.
Et de plus,
si Dieu a décidé
dans sa providence
que cette lettre
ferait partie
de sa parole,
alors nous pouvons
être assurés
de la cohérence
de Jacques
avec tout autre
rédacteur
des Écritures.
Cette mise au point
très importante
est en fait,
laissez-moi vous poser
une question,
à l'image de Jacques
sans transition.
Vous est-il déjà arrivé
de favoriser
une personne
par rapport
à une autre ?
Au travail,
dans la famille,
à l'Église ?
Est-ce que vous traitez
certains frères
ou certaines sœurs
de l'assemblée
mieux que d'autres ?
Et si oui,
selon quels critères
accordez-vous
ces faveurs ?
Mes frères,
que votre foi
en notre glorieux
Seigneur Jésus-Christ
soit exempte
de toute exception
de personne,
écrit Jacques
au premier verset
du chapitre 2.
Si nous sommes chrétiens,
nous ne pouvons pas
faire de favoritisme.
Le saviez-vous ?
Aviez-vous conscience
que le favoritisme
était un péché
selon la Bible ?
Et si oui,
êtes-vous sûrs
d'avoir bien saisi
en quoi consiste
ce péché de ne pas
le confondre par exemple
avec la négation
de tout honneur,
de tout privilège,
de toute distinction,
de toute hiérarchie ?
La Bible nous surprend
chaque jour, n'est-ce pas ?
En nous montrant
à quel point
notre perception
des choses
a besoin d'être restaurée
d'après celle de Dieu.
Quel que soit
notre point de départ,
il est très rare
que nous n'ayons pas
d'ajustement à faire.
Et en ce qui concerne
nos rapports aux autres,
il est certain
que le travail
de restauration
est conséquent
pour chacun d'entre nous.
Peut-être ne vous attendiez-vous
pas à ce que Jacques cite
l'acception de personnes
ou favoritisme
au milieu d'autres péchés
plus évidents
tels que l'orgueil,
la médisance,
l'incrédulité
ou l'hypocrisie religieuse.
Et pourtant,
il nous met en garde
contre l'acception de personnes,
contre le favoritisme
ou la partialité,
qui sont des tendances
charnelles
contre lesquelles
nous luttons
encore après notre conversion.
Il nous faut donc
comprendre
pourquoi le favoritisme
est en effet
un péché,
selon Dieu,
et trouver le remède
pour vaincre
ce péché.
Le favoritisme découle
directement
des critères
que nous utilisons
pour nous évaluer,
nous,
et les autres.
Et selon Dieu lui-même,
voici le critère principal
que l'humanité
utilise pour faire cela.
1 Samuel 16,
verset 7,
qui sera le verset
qui nous servira
de colonne vertébrale
pour ce serment.
Ce verset dit
« L'homme regarde
à ce qui frappe
les yeux,
mais l'Éternel
regarde au cœur. »
Voici donc
le plan
que nous allons suivre
pour répondre
à cette question.
Tout d'abord,
nous allons voir
ce qu'est l'acception
de personne.
Il nous faut savoir
de quoi nous parlons.
Ensuite,
nous verrons
ce qu'est la richesse
selon la chair.
Ensuite,
ce qu'est la pauvreté
selon la chair.
Puis,
nous verrons
quel est le remède
à ce péché
de l'acception
de personne.
Le premier verset
du chapitre 2
nous indique clairement
que notre foi
en notre glorieux
Seigneur Jésus-Christ
est purement
et simplement
incompatible
avec toute
exception de personne
ou tout favoritisme.
La version
François Martin
rend cette recommandation
peut-être encore
plus facile à comprendre
en disant
« Mes frères,
n'ayez point la foi
en notre Seigneur
Jésus-Christ glorieux
en ayant égard
à l'apparence
des personnes. »
Pourtant,
Dieu a créé
le concept
de hiérarchie.
Toute sa création
du macro au micro
est organisée
hiérarchiquement.
Dieu fait de très
nettes distinctions
entre les hommes.
Il récompense
certains plus que d'autres.
Il juge.
Comment cela
s'accorde-t-il
avec le fait
qu'il ne fasse
pourtant aucune
exception
de personne ?
Cela nous permet
de commencer
en définissant
ce que cette exhortation
de Jacques
ne veut pas dire.
premièrement,
nous ne sommes pas
appelés à abolir
toute forme
de hiérarchie.
La réponse
à ce péché
du favoritisme
n'est pas,
par exemple,
le communisme
où tout le monde
aurait le même
statut social
et le même
niveau de richesse.
La création de Dieu
est éminemment
hiérarchique.
Nous-mêmes,
êtres humains,
sommes la couronne
de la création.
Psaume 8,
verset 5,
Ces versets
prophétisent
Christ,
mais il parle
de Christ
dans son humanité,
il parle de nous
en tant qu'être humain
au-dessus
de la création.
Lié à ce principe
de hiérarchie,
nous ne sommes pas
appelés à abolir
tout rapport
d'autorité
sous mission.
Dieu a institué
l'État
pour qu'il ait
le pouvoir
de l'épée
afin de maintenir
l'ordre
et de rendre
la justice.
L'épouse doit être
soumise à son mari,
les enfants
à leurs parents,
les membres
d'église aux anciens,
Hébreu 13,
verset 17,
et tout homme
à Dieu.
Il ne s'agit pas
non plus
de ne pas accorder
l'honneur
qui revient
légitimement
à certaines personnes.
Dieu nous ordonne
même d'honorer
nos parents,
les anciens
de notre église locale
qui sont même dignes
d'un double honneur,
les autorités civiles
ou encore
les personnes âgées.
Dieu ne nous appelle
pas non plus
à effacer
toute distinction
entre les individus
ou groupes d'individus.
Dieu distingue
entre les justes
et les méchants,
entre son peuple
et les autres.
Il a aimé Jacob
et aïe Esaü.
nous,
en ce qui nous concerne,
nous serons plus
redevables devant Dieu
du soin que nous aurons pris
de notre famille
plutôt que des autres,
de nos proches,
des frères et soeurs
en crise
de notre église locale
plutôt que de personnes
démunies
à l'autre bout du monde.
Et enfin,
ne pas faire
de favoritisme,
ce n'est pas arrêter
d'exercer
le discernement spirituel
ou même
d'exercer
de justes jugements
et la discipline
d'église.
L'apôtre Jean
nous appelle à
éprouver les esprits
pour savoir
s'ils sont de Dieu.
Ou encore,
un verset très important
pour ce matin,
à ne pas juger
selon l'apparence
mais selon la justice.
Et l'apôtre Paul,
quant à lui,
nous appelle à
ôter le méchant
du milieu de nous.
Donc le but de Jacques
n'est évidemment pas
dans ce premier verset,
dans ces quatre premiers versets,
de nous encourager
à nier toute forme
de hiérarchie,
d'autorité,
d'honneur,
de distinction
entre les personnes
et de jugement
entre frères et sœurs
au sein de l'Église
puisque l'enseignement
de toutes les Écritures
est très clair
sur ces sujets.
Toutes ces choses,
loin d'être des péchés,
sont au contraire
des commandements de Dieu
et nous devons y obéir
le mieux possible.
Pensez-vous
ne pas être concerné
par cette exhortation
de Jacques
car vous êtes contre
toute forme
de distinction
entre les hommes,
contre toute forme
de double honneur
envers les pasteurs,
de confrontation
et de jugement
envers les frères
non repentants
de votre assemblée,
de soumission
de la femme
à son mari,
d'autorité
du mari
sur sa femme
et ses enfants.
Selon ces versets
que nous venons de citer,
non seulement cela
ne prouverait pas
que vous êtes exempt
de tout favoritisme
dans votre vie,
mais ça rendrait par contre
évident que vous désobéissez
à d'autres commandements
très clairs
de la parole.
Voilà pourquoi
il est important
de définir
les termes théologiques
que nous utilisons
selon la Bible
et non selon notre instinct,
nos impressions,
nos préférences,
notre sensibilité,
notre éducation
ou notre culture.
Le problème
de l'acception
de personne
est plus grave
et son origine
bien plus sombre
qu'il n'y paraît.
C'est bien plus
qu'un simple manque
de tact
entre les membres
de l'Église
ou de critères
de réussite
dans la vie
un peu nul.
Et maintenant
que nous savons
ce qu'elle n'est pas,
voyons plus précisément
ce qu'est l'acception
de personne
en commençant
donc par
la richesse
selon la chair.
Verset 3
nous y lisons.
Si tournant
vos regards
vers celui
qui porte
l'habit magnifique,
vous lui dites
« Toi,
assieds-toi ici
à cette place
d'honneur. »
Pour ceux
qui prennent des notes
et pour les autres
qui retiennent tout,
voici donc
la définition
de l'acception
de personne.
L'acception
de personne
ou favoritisme
c'est traiter
quelqu'un
selon des critères
humains
charnels
qui sont
superficiels
partiaux
ou intéressés
par l'apparence,
la richesse,
le statut
plutôt que selon
la justice,
la vérité
et l'amour.
L'acception
de personne
ou favoritisme
c'est traiter
quelqu'un
selon des critères
humains
charnels
qui sont superficiels
partiaux
ou intéressés
par l'apparence,
la richesse,
le statut
plutôt que selon
la justice,
la vérité
et l'amour.
Nous faisons preuve
de favoritisme
lorsque nous
traitons notre prochain
sous l'influence
de notre chair
et non sous l'influence
du Saint-Esprit.
Nous maintenons
ces notions
que nous avons vues
de hiérarchie,
d'autorité,
d'honneur,
de distinction,
de jugement,
mais nous exerçons
tout cela
sur la base
de critères
corrompus
par le reste
de péchés
qui demeurent
malheureusement
dans notre cœur.
Non seulement cela
corrompt notre
appréciation
des personnes
mais aussi
notre attitude
envers elles.
Nous honorons
d'une mauvaise manière
celui que nous jugeons
digne selon
de mauvais critères
et nous dénigrons
celui que nous jugeons
indigne aussi
selon de mauvais critères.
Et cela peut revêtir
beaucoup de formes
dans nos vies,
dans nos églises.
Mais dans le contexte
des églises
auxquelles Jacques écrit
le verset 2
nous apprend
que ces chrétiens
pouvaient avoir tendance
à honorer le riche
parce qu'il était riche
et à dénigrer le pauvre
parce qu'il était pauvre.
Mauvaise attitude
sur la base
de mauvais critères.
Il est probable
qu'il y avait en effet
de grands écarts
de richesse
entre les membres
de ces églises.
Comme je vous l'ai rappelé
tout à l'heure,
beaucoup avaient fui
la persécution
en laissant
leur bien derrière eux
et ils se retrouvaient
dans ces assemblées
avec les habitants
des villes
dans lesquelles
ils avaient trouvé refuge
qui eux possédaient
encore tout leur bien
et certains
en grande quantité.
Et il n'est donc pas étonnant
que Jacques ait exhorté
ces deux catégories
de personnes,
les riches
et les pauvres,
au chapitre 1
et qu'ils reviennent
sur ce sujet ici
plus en détail.
Car dans un tel
contexte d'église,
ces écarts de richesse
pouvaient être
tour à tour
cause de tentations,
de recherches
de gloire personnelle,
de jugements
partiels
comme dans ces versets
ou même d'oppression
comme nous le verrons
une prochaine fois.
Comme nous l'avons vu,
il n'y a aucun mal
à honorer
certaines personnes
parmi d'autres,
plus que d'autres.
Lorsque nous donnons
la meilleure chaise
ou la meilleure place
à un pasteur invité
le dimanche par exemple,
nous ne sommes pas coupables
d'acception de personne.
Au contraire,
nous honorons celui
que Dieu nous demande
d'honorer même doublement
dans sa parole.
Il n'y a pas non plus
de problème
avec la richesse
en soi.
Dieu est infiniment riche.
Il accorde de grandes richesses
à certains de ses enfants.
L'abondance
était la norme
avant la chute
et elle le sera aussi
dans l'éternité.
La beauté extérieure
n'est pas mauvaise non plus.
Dieu est infiniment beau.
Il a créé,
aime et entretient
la beauté.
Il est normal
d'aimer
et de rechercher
la gloire,
la beauté
et la richesse.
En réalité,
ce n'est pas notre chair
qui nous attire
vers ces choses.
C'est bien l'image
de Dieu en nous
qui nous attire
vers ces choses.
Mais le problème,
comme toujours
avec le péché
et c'est très important
pour vous
de comprendre ce principe
au-delà
du seul péché
de favoritisme.
Le problème,
c'est que
les destinataires
de Jacques
honorent ces choses
qui sont bonnes
en elles-mêmes,
mais selon
ce qui frappe
leurs yeux,
selon des critères
charnels,
superficiels
et potentiellement
intéressés.
Ils approuvent
et honorent
la gloire,
la beauté
et la richesse,
mais selon
les valeurs
et les motivations
de leur chair
et non celle
de l'Esprit de Dieu,
ce qui transforme
l'honneur
qu'ils rendent
aux riches
en acception
de personnes.
Qu'est-ce qui pousse
la chair
de ces chrétiens
à favoriser
ainsi ceux
qui ont
une apparence
de richesse ?
Quel type
de richesse
a de la valeur
aux yeux
de notre chair ?
Car il faut bien
comprendre
que ceux
qui se rendaient
coupables
d'un tel favoritisme
dans ces églises
ne le faisaient pas
envers des personnes
dont ils étaient
sûrs
qu'elles étaient riches
un homme
avec un anneau d'or
et un habit
magnifique.
Si,
tournant vos regards
vers celui
qui porte
l'habit magnifique,
vous lui dites
« Toi,
assieds-toi ici
à cette place
d'honneur. »
Vous voyez,
il s'agit
d'une réaction
instinctive,
d'un réflexe
quasiment
d'une pulsion
qui entre dans le cœur
par la fenêtre
des yeux
et en ressort
sous forme
de favoritisme
envers cette apparence
de richesse.
Seuls les riches
pouvaient s'offrir
de telles bagues.
C'est vrai.
Si pour certains
la raison
n'était qu'esthétique,
le plus souvent
il faut le reconnaître,
elle servait
à afficher
extérieurement
leur statut social
et les plus prétentieux
d'entre eux
en portaient même
à chaque doigt
sauf aux majeurs.
Certaines sources
mentionnent même
l'existence
de tout un marché
de bagues
de locations,
ce qui appuie
cette idée
d'une compétition
par la course
à la démesure
parmi les riches
dans cette culture.
Il était,
et c'est important
pour la suite
de cette prédication,
encore plus important
de paraître riche
que d'être riche.
L'apparence
avant la réalité,
ce qui frappe
les yeux
avant le cœur.
alors il nous est impossible
de dire s'il avait
de telles riches
de façades
emplies de prétentions
dans ces églises
auxquelles Jacques écrit
et s'il y en avait,
nous ne pouvons pas dire
en quelle proportion.
D'ailleurs,
puisque Jacques dit
supposer qu'il entre,
il s'agit
d'une situation hypothétique.
Cela dit,
s'il choisit
d'en parler,
c'est soit
que cela est déjà arrivé
dans les églises,
soit qu'il suppose
fortement
que cela arrivera.
Et dans ce cas,
il est fort probable
que parmi ces riches
dont il parle,
certains l'étaient vraiment
mais d'autres
jouaient ou surjouaient
aux riches.
L'anneau d'or,
l'habit magnifique,
ils ne sont pas
pointés du doigt
par Jacques
en tant que tel,
mais pour ce qu'ils traduisent
souvent
de la personne
qui les porte
et toujours
de celle
qui honore
cette apparence
de richesse.
Un cœur orgueilleux,
prétentieux,
vaniteux,
rempli de convoitises
et qui cherche
sa propre gloire.
Et ce que cela démontre,
frères et sœurs,
si nous continuons
de creuser
dans les tréfonds
tortueux
de nos cœurs,
c'est qu'à la racine,
à la source
de l'acception
de personne,
se trouve en réalité
l'insatisfaction,
l'ingratitude
et la convoitise.
Nous nous comparons
aux autres
et nous voulons
ce qu'ils ont.
nous voulons plus
que ce qu'ils ont.
Il s'agit ici
de richesse matérielle
mais il peut s'agir
du nombre d'amis,
du type de travail,
du ministère
dans l'Église,
de l'apparence physique
ou que sais-je encore.
Les chrétiens
qui font
exception de personnes
sont comme le dit Jacques
au chapitre 1,
amorcés par leur
propre
convoitise
qui conçoit
et enfante
ce péché.
Ces chrétiens
voient cette apparence
de richesse
chez les autres
et tout d'un coup
leur cœur
convoite cette apparence
et toutes les opportunités
qu'elle évoque
et ils s'empressent
de favoriser le riche
car au fond d'eux-mêmes
c'est ce qu'ils espèrent
être un jour.
Car ils regardent
à ce qui frappe les yeux
et ne s'intéressent pas
au cœur,
ils jugent
selon l'apparence
et non selon
la justice.
Lorsqu'ils placent
le riche
au-dessus d'eux
et le pauvre
en dessous
car c'est bien
ce qu'ils font
« Assieds-toi
au-dessous
de mon marche-pied »
disent-ils
aux pauvres.
Ils ne font que montrer
ce qu'il y a vraiment
dans leur cœur,
ce qui a vraiment
de la valeur
pour eux.
Ils se sentent
à mi-chemin
de la réussite,
supérieurs aux pauvres
mais pas encore
au niveau du riche.
Ce favoritisme
envers les riches
c'est donc à la fois
une réaction
auto-centrée,
orgueilleuse
et superficielle,
vaine.
Ils voient le riche
entrer,
ils s'imaginent
à sa place,
ils le traitent
comme ils aimeraient
être traités,
encore une fois
un bon principe
mais selon
des critères
corrompus
par le péché
sous l'inspiration
de pensées mauvaises
comme le dit Jacques
au verset 4
et je dirais même
pour en arriver
au cœur
de notre sujet
sous l'inspiration
de pensées
sataniques.
pourquoi les pensées
mauvaises de notre
chair qui nous
mènent à favoriser
injustement une ou des
personnes sont-elles
sataniques ?
Satan était un modèle
de perfection,
plein de sagesse,
parfait en beauté,
intègre dans ses voies
depuis le jour où il fut
créé jusqu'à ce que
l'iniquité soit trouvée
en lui.
Ésaïe 28
verset 12 à 17
et voici la phrase
la plus importante
son cœur
s'est enorgueilli
de sa beauté
il a corrompu
sa sagesse
par son éclat
Satan lui-même
a chuté
parce qu'il a regardé
ce qui frappait
ses yeux
l'éclat
de sa propre beauté
qu'il a rempli
d'orgueil
orgueil
qui l'a ensuite mené
à convoiter
la place de Dieu
son créateur
comme le dit Ésaïe
tu disais en ton cœur
je monterai au ciel
j'élèverai mon trône
au-dessus des étoiles
de Dieu
je serai semblable
au très haut
Satan a convoité
la splendeur de Dieu
et surtout l'adoration
qu'il recevait
de ses créatures
il aurait pu regarder
au cœur
de Dieu
s'émerveiller
des perfections
des attributs
de Dieu
chercher à les imiter
le plus possible
à ressembler
à ce Dieu merveilleux
mais il a plutôt
regardé à ce qui
frappe les yeux
et ce n'est même pas
la gloire de Dieu
qu'il convoitait
mais l'impact
que cette gloire avait
sur les créatures
de Dieu
l'adoration
les louanges
que Dieu recevait
en réponse
à l'éclat
de sa gloire
Satan était suffisamment
glorieux
pour être rempli
d'orgueil
mais pas suffisamment
pour satisfaire
cet orgueil
et n'est-ce pas là
le drame
de nos cœurs
dans lequel
demeure
un reste
de l'esprit
de sonde
un reste
de l'esprit
de Satan
n'est-ce pas
de cette manière
que Satan
a tenté Ève
en lui faisant croire
comme il se l'était dit
à lui-même
qu'elle serait
semblable
au Très-Haut
n'est-ce pas
son propre désir
de gloire personnelle
égal à celle de Dieu
qui l'insuffla
dans le cœur
de Ève
la poussant
à convoiter
le fruit défendu
puis finalement
à se rebeller
à sa suite
contre Dieu
n'est-ce pas
le même esprit
de recherche
de gloire personnelle
et de convoitise
qui pousse
les destinataires
de Jacques
à honorer
charnellement
les riches
dont ils espèrent
au fond
faire partie
pour recevoir
à leur tour
louange
honneur
de la part
des hommes
voyez ce qui pousse
la chair
à chercher
ou à honorer
l'apparence
de richesse
ce sont des valeurs
et des motivations
purement sataniques
il s'agit de convoiter
la gloire de Dieu
pour détourner
l'adoration
de ses créatures
vers nous
c'est ce que font
tous les enfants
de Satan
d'une manière
ou d'une autre
en suivant l'exemple
de leur père
ainsi que le dit
Jésus
aux juifs
incrédules
vous avez pour père
le diable
et vous voulez
accomplir
les désirs
de votre père
lorsque les chrétiens
favorisent
ceux qui ont
une apparence
de richesse
ils accomplissent
les désirs
du diable
et n'oublions pas
qu'une gloire feinte
attire une adoration
feinte
hypocrite
de la flatterie
tout ne devient
alors qu'un théâtre
d'illusions malsaines
une gloire feinte
dissimulant orgueil
prétention
et soif
de gloire personnelle
un honneur
dissimulant convoitise
qui n'est que flatterie
c'est l'esprit
de cour
l'église
qui se remplit
de courtisans
qui n'ont en tête
que de s'attirer
les faveurs des riches
en attendant
de prendre leur place
c'est l'esprit
des pharisiens
qui n'avaient de cesse
de mettre en avant
leur statut social
qui convoitait
les places d'honneur
dans les synagogues
qui plaçait leur parole
au dessus
de celle de Dieu
et qui dévorait
la maison
des veuves
oui frères et sœurs
car cet esprit
satanique
qui peut encore
animer notre chair
même en tant que chrétien
ne nous pousse pas
uniquement à convoiter
la gloire des riches
et les louanges
qu'ils reçoivent
ils nous poussent
aussi à dénigrer
à mépriser
à exploiter
à rejeter le pauvre
ces deux attitudes
vont malheureusement
très souvent de pair
et nous allons voir
pourquoi
verset 3
si vous dites au pauvre
toi
tiens-toi là debout
ou bien
assis-toi au-dessous
de mon marche-pied
la pauvreté
selon la chair
et le fait d'avoir vu
pourquoi la chair
flatte
l'apparence de richesse
va nous aider
à comprendre
par contraste
pourquoi elle méprise
l'apparence de pauvreté
car il s'agit bien
du même principe
mais tout simplement
inversé
celui qui a l'habit magnifique
est honoré
et celui qui est
misérablement vêtu
est méprisé
et vous ne serez pas étonné
maintenant
si je vous dis
que c'est le même esprit
satanique
et lorsque je parle
d'esprit satanique
je parle de valeur
je parle des objectifs
de la façon de penser
bref de la volonté
de Satan
et pas de son esprit
en tant qu'entité
qui nous posséderait
vous ne serez pas
donc étonné
si je vous dis que
c'est ce même esprit
qui pousse
ces chrétiens
à agir
ainsi
envers le pauvre
dans leur église
satan est le père
de l'orgueil
de l'amour
de soi
et dans un sens
comparé à lui
qui était
comme nous l'avons lu
un modèle de perfection
qui était parfait
en beauté
adam et eve
étaient comme ce pauvre
misérablement vêtu
qui entre dans l'église
et frustré
de savoir
que dieu serait
toujours plus glorieux
que lui
satan a assoui
sa frustration
et sa haine de dieu
en abusant
des plus pauvres
que lui
adam et eve
puisqu'il ne pouvait pas
s'élever au dessus de dieu
il a décidé
de sournoisement
abaisser au plus bas
tous ceux
qu'il pouvait
tout en leur promettant
de les élever
à la hauteur de dieu
voici ce qu'il a
faussement promis
à eve
le jour où vous
mangerez de ce fruit
vos yeux s'ouvriront
et vous serez
comme les dieux
en détournant
le coeur des hommes
de dieu vers lui
satan les a
projetés au plus
profond de l'enfer
par soif
de s'élever
à la hauteur de dieu
satan
abaisse
les plus faibles
que lui
par soif
de s'élever
à la hauteur de dieu
satan
abaisse
les plus faibles
que lui
et il a réussi
à nous rallier
à sa cause
et aujourd'hui
l'humanité
agit envers son prochain
sous l'influence
de l'esprit de satan
qui a imprégné
sa chair
et ne pouvant pas
tomber plus bas
qu'il ne l'est déjà
en enfer
désirant s'élever
mais ne le pouvant
pas non plus
l'humanité
est comme un tas
de rats
au fond d'un seau
se montant
les uns sur les autres
se dévorant
les uns les autres
afin de pouvoir
gravir les parois
mais finissant toujours
par retomber
au fond du seau
soit pour recommencer
soit pour se faire
piétiner
à leur tour
telle est la réalité
de notre humanité
que satan
veut nous faire
oublier
frères et sœurs
satan veut nous faire
oublier la réalité
de notre pauvreté
de notre misère
spirituelle
en la maquillant
sous une apparence
de richesse
et c'est alors
que le pauvre
débarque
dans cette mise
en scène macabre
dans ce carnaval
de cadavres
grossièrement costumés
lui le mal vêtu
lui qui ne possède
rien d'attirant
qui n'a pas le costume
de la fête
tout de repoussant
pour la chair
qui a peur
d'être démasqué
dévoilé
de perdre
son maquillage
notre chair
animée des mêmes désirs
que satan
méprise les pauvres
car il nous rappelle
à tous
qui nous sommes réellement
à l'intérieur
que ce soit individuellement
ou en tant qu'humanité
déchue
satan et notre chair
n'aiment pas le pauvre
car en le côtoyant
nous pouvons prendre conscience
de notre misère spirituelle
et vouloir donc saisir
la grâce de Dieu
en Jésus Christ
satan veut constamment
nous faire croire
que nous sommes libres
que nous sommes riches
en sécurité
dans un monde
où tous nos désirs
peuvent être accomplis
que tout va bien
et le pauvre
par son état
vient nous rappeler
que nous sommes
en réalité
condamnés
pauvres
et en danger
de mort éternelle
déjà
mort
spirituellement
le pauvre
est une tâche
sur le tableau
que satan veut nous peindre
une fausse note
dans la berceuse envoûtante
qu'il veut nous jouer
c'est donc non seulement
l'élan naturel
de la chair
d'abaisser les autres
pour s'élever
mais à cela
se rajoute la haine
envers tout ce que le pauvre
dans son état
nous rappelle de nous-mêmes
le rejet
le mépris
l'oppression
vers le pauvre
ne sont que le reflet
du dégoût
que l'homme pêcheur
a de lui-même
de ce qu'il a perdu
à cause de son péché
sa beauté
sa prospérité
sa gloire initiale
de ce qu'il est devenu
à cause de ce péché
démuni
pauvre
misérable
et de ce qu'il deviendra
à cause de son péché
éternellement
mis à mort
en enfer
un jour
nous avons regardé
un film
avec mon épouse
une satire sociale
sur le culte du corps
et de la jeunesse
de la femme
où le personnage principal
est une actrice
en fin de carrière
puisqu'elle commence
à devenir trop âgée
par rapport aux autres femmes
et une entreprise
lui propose un produit
qui lui permet
de se dédoubler
une semaine
elle vit en tant qu'une version
plus jeune d'elle-même
et la semaine d'après
en tant que sa version actuelle
plus âgée
et je vous passe les détails
mais les choses
tournent très mal
et le produit
finit par la transformer
en une chimère
monstrueuse
et le soir même
où elle doit donner
la plus grande représentation
de l'année
en public
cela se produit
et donc elle tente
de mettre
malgré tout sa robe
de se maquiller
et le résultat
est horrible
totalement insuffisant
pour masquer
sa monstruosité
mais elle se présente
quand même en public
ce qui finit par
créer un élan
de panique
lorsque la foule
aperçoit
ce monstre
voici ce que nous sommes
lorsque nous pensons
pouvoir cacher
notre réalité intérieure
sous une apparence
de beauté
de richesse
et de gloire
devant Dieu
qui voit tout
nous sommes
comme des monstres
hideux
qui tentent
de se revêtir
et de se maquiller
cela est inutile
grotesque
et repoussant
au delà de nous même
les pauvres
nous rappellent
la réalité
de ce monde maudit
ils viennent briser
l'illusion satanique
du paradis sur terre
sans Dieu
ils nous rappellent
qu'un jour
nous vivions
dans l'abondance
du jardin d'Éden
et qu'aujourd'hui
nous vivons
dans un monde
en ruines
où les portes d'Éden
sont fermées
et où le paradis
n'existe pas
et n'existera jamais
et finalement
ils nous rappellent
ce que nous devrions être
non seulement
en tant que créature humaine
mais d'autant plus
déchue
ayant entraîné
le monde
dans notre chute
nous devrions être
remplis
d'humilité
et d'affliction
face à ce triste constat
et non d'orgueil
et de fierté
voilà pourquoi
Jésus Christ
est allé vers les pauvres
et les démunis
non seulement
parce qu'il avait
une vraie pitié
de ces personnes
qui souffraient
dans leurs conditions
de vie terrestre
mais aussi
parce qu'en prenant soin d'eux
il accomplissait
une sorte de
métaphore prophétique
qui nous montre
quelle est la situation
spirituelle
et le besoin spirituel
de chacun d'entre nous
devant Dieu
auquel lui seul
Christ
peut répondre
il y a donc une lutte
entre l'esprit de Satan
qui veut maintenir
les hommes en enfer
par cette illusion
de prospérité
et l'esprit de Christ
qui veut briser
cette illusion
en nous rappelant
que nous sommes
spirituellement pauvres
démunis
misérables
afin de nous emmener
avec lui
au paradis
heureux
les pauvres
en esprit
car le royaume
des cieux
est à eux
enseigna notre
Seigneur Jésus
être pauvre
ce n'est pas un ticket
d'entrée
automatique
au paradis
mais reconnaître
et confesser
que nous sommes
à leur image
pauvres
spirituellement
revêtus
des haillons
de notre péché
nus
et sans défense
devant Dieu
impropres
à la vie au paradis
et que nous avons
besoin du glorieux
manteau de justice
du Christ
pour y entrer
voilà la prise de conscience
qui est un premier pas
vers la repentance
qui mène au salut
voilà frères et sœurs
les raisons qui poussent
la chair à ignorer
mépriser
rabaisser
opprimer
et exploiter
les pauvres
la veuve
et l'orphelin
tous ceux qui sont
sans défense
sans statut social
et n'est-ce pas
ce que nous observons
dans notre monde
depuis la nuit des temps
cela vient
de l'esprit satanique
qui a imprégné
notre chair
et qui nous pousse
sans arrêt
à vouloir
comme Satan
nous élever
plus haut que Dieu
en rabaissant les autres
en dessous de nous
et en exploitant
tous ceux au-dessus
desquels
nous avons réussi
à nous élever
des rats au fond
d'un seau
voilà ce qu'est
l'humanité
sans Christ
cette mascarade
peut durer au mieux
toute la vie
mais elle prendra
fin un jour
et c'est bien
dans leur état
de pauvreté
nue
sale
et sans
aucune possession
que ceux
qui rejettent
Christ
paraîtront
devant Dieu
car ce jour-là
les habits
somptueux
les anneaux d'or
seront consumés
par sa lumière
éclatante
et pure
alors frères et sœurs
quelle église
voulons-nous être
par quel esprit
animés
celui de Satan
qui cache
la dure réalité
spirituelle de l'homme
pour le maintenir
en enfer
ou celui de Christ
qui met cette dure réalité
de notre état spirituel
au grand jour
mais pour nous emmener
avec lui
au paradis
serons-nous
une église
qui honore les apparences
sans se préoccuper
de l'état du cœur
ou serons-nous
une église
pour qui l'état du cœur
est la priorité absolue
car c'est la santé
de notre âme
qui détermine
notre éternité
nous traiterons-nous
les uns les autres
selon des critères
charnels
superficiels
partiaux
intéressés
ou selon la justice
la vérité
et l'amour du Christ
tel est l'enjeu
de ces versets de Jacques
ne pas juger
selon l'apparence
mais selon
la justice
voilà donc
frères et sœurs
pourquoi l'acception
de personne
est un péché
si grave
c'est un comportement
diamétralement opposé
à celui de Dieu
car il est d'origine satanique
il s'agit en réalité
d'approuver
et d'honorer
la recherche
de gloire personnelle
au détriment des autres
honorer
ce que Dieu rejette
et mépriser
ce qu'il honore
voici le résultat
de regarder à ce qui
frappe les yeux
et non au cœur
c'est donc une attitude
qui nie totalement
l'évangile
et son impact
dans notre vie
depuis la chute
d'Adam et Ève
l'humanité tombe
encore et encore
dans le même piège
tendu par Satan
se laisser séduire
par les apparences
en négligeant
la réalité intérieure
honorer
ce qui est sans importance
ou même néfaste
et rejeter
ce qui a de la valeur
aux yeux de Dieu
adorer la créature
à la place du Créateur
l'adorer lui Satan
à la place de Dieu
quel est donc
le remède
à cette exception
de personne
nous ne ferons que
l'évoquer ce matin
avant d'y revenir
plus en détail
une prochaine fois
mais Jacques l'évoque
donc au verset 1
pour combattre
et vaincre
cet élan satanique
de notre chair
nous devons sans cesse
contempler
la gloire
de notre Seigneur
Jésus Christ
contrairement à Satan
qui s'élève
en abaissant
les misérables
notre glorieux
Seigneur Jésus Christ
s'abaisse
pour les élever
malgré les apparences
Satan appauvrit
le riche
il enlédit la beauté
il corrompt
la vertu
Christ quant à lui
anoblit le pauvre
il restaure
la création en ruines
et redonne vie
aux eaux desséchées
que nous étions
par orgueil
et dans sa haine
Satan a plongé le monde
dans le mensonge
et les ténèbres
et par amour
et en toute humilité
Christ y a fait resplendir
la lumière
de la vérité
Satan nous a apporté
la mort
et Christ
la vie éternelle
Heureux les pauvres
en esprit
car le royaume de Dieu
est à eux
l'esprit de Christ
nous révèle
nos ténèbres intérieures
pour nous ouvrir
à la lueur
de sa grâce
Frères et Sœurs
apprenons
à aller plus loin
que ce que nous comprenons
lors d'une première lecture
superficielle
aviez-vous conscience
de la gravité
de ce péché
d'acception de personne
aviez-vous conscience
des horribles pensées
de l'esprit satanique
qui est à l'origine
de cette attitude
quelle que soit la forme
qu'elle revêt
dans notre vie
nous oublions parfois
à quel point
notre nature humaine
a été profondément
corrompue
par le péché
et d'où ce péché vient
alors sous l'inspiration
de quelle pensée
allez-vous juger
votre prochain
apprenons Frères et Sœurs
à nous voir
comme le plus misérable
des pauvres
la gloire de Christ
et de son amour
pour nous
n'en sera que plus exaltée
et le témoignage
que nous rendrons
au monde
n'en sera que plus rayonnant
si nous devons
nous enorgueillir
de quelque chose
que ce soit
de connaître Dieu
en Jésus Christ
ainsi que le dit
le prophète Jérémie
que celui qui veut
se glorifier
se glorifie
d'avoir de l'intelligence
et de me connaître
de savoir
que je suis l'éternel
qui exerce la bonté
le droit
et la justice
sur la terre
alors chers assemblés
ne tombons pas
dans le piège du diable
en honorant
l'habit magnifique
et l'anneau d'or
mais servons
notre Seigneur
Jésus Christ
en honorant
le manteau
de sa justice
dont il a revêtu
chacun d'entre nous
que tous nos regards
se tournent vers lui
reste braqué sur lui
afin de nous oublier
nous-mêmes
afin qu'il n'y ait
dans notre assemblée
plus ni riche
ni pauvre
mais uniquement
des rebelles graciers
des esclaves
inoubli
des orphelins
adoptés
des étrangers
accueillis
uniquement des misérables
tous magnifiquement
revêtus
de justice
par Dieu leur Père
et dont les yeux
ne peuvent contenir
l'intensité
de la gloire
qu'ils contemplent
la gloire
de notre glorieux
Seigneur Jésus Christ
est en train de se déranger
de la gloire